good afternoon it's half first one and
you're joining us for a special question
and answer program with our panel of Sky
News expert editors to talk about the
financial crisis affecting the pound
join me to answer your questions are
City editor Mark Kleinman our business
presenter Ian King and our economics and
data editor Ed Conway I've got loads of
questions actually lots of people are
watching and I've got lots of questions
let's whiz through them and let's try
and keep our answer short
um I'll start with you Ed Jonathan has
got in touch he says is it possible the
mini budget could work of given time is
it a case of holding on nerve there's
lots of really interesting kind of good
supply side reformers in the in the
budget
um and if there weren't this terrible
Market chaos or supply side reforms
sorry Supply it's basically kind of
taking different bits of the economy
that could work a bit better and making
them work better whether that's like
planning so so essentially kind of
you've got planning make us make it
easier to build homes you've got kind of
you know infrastructure all of that
stuff
um if it was actually implemented that
could really help growth uh there's
interest and also changing kind of the
capital allowances scheme so businesses
can basically invest more and not have
to pay as much tax on that but the issue
is We're In This Storm at the moment and
so right now the storm is the story you
know if we spend all our time talking
about supply side reforms which is what
the government wants to do we're not
addressing this massive fire that's
happening right now so
that's a no then
um for the time being in to You Les has
got in touch where does the Bank of
England get 68 billion pounds to buy
debt are we effectively just printing
money and if so will that further weaken
the currency well it's electronic money
create I mean essentially the bank of
England creates money electronically and
then we'll buy these guilds in the
markets and people have paid according
it's exactly the same as the way that
quantitative easing Works
um it's a big expansion of the money
supply it's a big expansion of the bank
of England's balance sheets uh does it
uh what was the second part of the
question does it um will it not weaken
the currency
not necessarily in a way it strengthened
it actually because uh because people
are like oh actually there's we don't
need to panic as much but the bank
though is desperate That No One Compares
it too much to QE yeah Quant state of
easing do I need to Define Quant state
of easing go on then it's when you pump
money into the you kind of electronics
and then put it in and get it in there
and they're like well it's not quite the
same because we're not putting it in
there to get more money flowing around
it specifically focusing on these
markets but that just shows you the more
Sinister question and the reason that
the bank by the way doesn't want people
to say it's like QE is because
effectively the government's just
announced a big big expansion in
borrowing and effectively you could say
the bank will mop up some of the extra
guilts that uh are being issued to pay
for that via QE that's why the debt
monetization as it's known in the jargon
the bank of England does not want anyone
talking or even hinting at that because
it chips away at the bank's Independence
Zimbabwe yeah
um so that which slightly links in with
the question that Matthew has what will
be the lasting impact of the bank of
England buying bonds and how will this
affect this generation and generations
to come Ian well ultimately the bank
that's I mean this is the great irony a
week ago today the monetary policy
committee had raised rates but the other
big significant thing which I remember
talking to you about at the time is that
they're also going to start unwinding
their asset purchases QE has said just
described it which began during the
financial crisis went on pause was
revived during the pandemic and the bank
has accumulated something like 868
billion pounds worth of uh of assets on
its balance sheet it's going to stop so
it was going to start selling those off
and selling that down ultimately it will
have to unwind those positions and start
reducing the size of its balance sheet
in exactly the same way by the way that
the U.S federal reserve is doing as well
and the European Central Bank is
committed to doing all of these banks
have expanded their balance sheets but
could then we'd be paying for that for
generations to come
um I mean potentially but it's it's it
because this is a monetary so because
they are kind of creating money to put
it into the system it's not quite the
same as like taking out new debts it's
you know potentially means you have a
kind of you well no the answer I think
the answer basically is the answer you
don't know it the answer I have no clue
I mean it's a bit of a wormhole QE
um
the answer is no okay it's not gonna
it's not the kind of debt that the
government takes on and kind of tries to
kind of you know lend to people uh it's
supposed to just kind of once it gets
withdrawn to be you know withdrawn from
the system uh through a kind of form of
tightening it's Bank Reserves which is
not which is very short-term form of
money but uh yeah I mean it gets me
ahead I quit thinking about this stuff
and don't forget I mean we've seen
ministers like Andrew Griffith yesterday
Chris philp this morning on Sky News all
talking about uh the fact that the UK's
debt to GDP ratio is actually lower than
most other G7 economies that's the
government's position that's why they
say look this extra borrowing we can
live with it but the other point is that
you know some of the other
um Western economies that you were
talking about earlier Jane that have had
to step in in recent uh weeks to uh to
support their currencies
all of this adds up to the fact that the
era of cheap debt that we saw after the
2008 banking crisis is now finally
looking like it's coming to an end and
the consequences of that may be Ed's
right and uh children and grandchildren
won't be dealing with the consequences
of what the bank of England has and the
government have done over the last week
but nevertheless there are consequences
from the unwinding of those banking
crisis era policies no doubt about that
okay
um uh I wondered when when brexit would
come into this discussion and fergal
Liston has brought it in uh give this
one to you mark would the government
have had the flexibility to impose such
a mini budget if the UK was still in the
European Union
um to a large degree yeah because the
government's still responsible for
domestic tax policy
um one exception to that would be the
the announcement last Friday about the
decision to uh remove the cap on Bank
bonuses which was a an EU a piece of EU
legislation introduced after the
financial crisis the government couldn't
have done that without uh without uh you
could couldn't have done that in inside
if the UK had remained inside the EU and
the other point is that that was part of
this
um broader push for deregulation in the
city and the financial services sector
that the government is is obviously very
very keen on but whether it can go ahead
with that now given the the current
crisis that we've been talking about for
the last couple of hours and that's
that's open to debate so I guess what
the person is trying to push at is if if
brexit hadn't happened would this mini
budget have not been able to happen well
the mini budget in itself would have
been able to happen and many of the
measures in it to do with income tax and
and some of the supply side reforms that
Ed was talking about yes for sure
certainly wouldn't have been able to
have happened in the UK been in the
Eurozone but the EU membership isn't an
issue okay
um Terry got in touch his question is
how did these changes go ahead without
scrutiny from the office of budget
responsibility
well the government said it didn't want
no be our forecast
and I mean well it kind of is the the
ABR has to produce two forecasts every
year uh it usually does them alongside
uh budgets and spending reviews and
stuff like that this time it offered to
do some it said it said we're not going
to be able to do quite as extensive
forecasts as we normally do because it's
quite a short time Horizon but we can we
can do it if you want to and the
chancellor said no and that's it it was
it was his decision and so it's not the
case that they have to do one well they
have to do two a year okay and so
they've done they've done one for the
budget earlier on this year the real
budget not that it was quite as big as
this one and they are going to do
another one on the 23rd of November we
now know and we knew that they were
going to do one another one within this
fiscal year but the key thing here is
they didn't do it this time around and
that was as far as I know that was
basically up to the chancellor he said
no thanks but isn't it you know my
question if you know that the obr has to
do another report by the end of the year
and you're putting together a mini
statement wouldn't it make sense to ask
them to do it into your budget yeah
so you want short answers yes okay fair
enough and we know they were primed to
it for it as well that was a bit of
information that the treasury select
committee wheedled out to them and one
of the points is that the treasury and
the government would not like us to have
concluded this but one of the reasons
for the extreme reactions that we've
seen over the last five or six days is
because there was no obr forecast built
in indeed and David Roy's question next
does this make an imminent UK market
crash inevitable and what Ripple effects
would that have on global markets Mark
do you want to have a no no it doesn't
make it inevitable I mean assuming that
the question is is based on uh the UK
stock markets no it's it's not
inevitable there's there's pressure
clearly on on equities at the moment
partly because of the uh the pressures
that we've seen this week emerging in
Pension funds which are having to sell
um shares in order to raise cash to make
the collateral calls so there's one
Dynamic that's taking place but no a
market crash is not inevitable we
haven't talked about uh the idea of uh
The Echoes of 2008 which have really
been for those of us who were covering
that uh banking crisis for nearly 15
years ago there have definitely been
some distinct Echoes In what we've seen
in terms of Market Behavior this week
but the key thing to say is that we are
not uh so far as I know on the brink of
a major banking crisis this is a
liquidity crisis that we've seen in
Pension funds for example uh this week
and there is obviously a crisis of
Market confidence in what the UK
government has announced but um it's
really difficult to talk about any
market crash being inevitable it's
actually worth pointing out that the
ftse 100 which has been a dog for the
last 20 years has actually been the best
performing Western Stock Market this
year it's only down by about four
percent since the beginning of the year
the s p and the Dow in the US are off by
20 22 percent uh all of the big Europe
Continental European stock markets are
down by much more than the ftse and the
ftse actually benefits from the falling
pound because something like 60 of all
company earnings from ftse companies is
derived in US dollars so you get a
stronger dollar that translates into
higher Sterling earnings when you do the
translation effect which is why all of
these big dollar earners have have kind
of kept the foots here float okay okay
um next question is from John this is
also about the link between the the
pound and the dollar what's the forecast
for the pound against the dollar the
exchange rate can we expect to see it
improve or do you think it'll drop
further in coming months possibly
reaching parity at some point
I'm always too loath to make a
prediction on currency there was a
former U.S treasury secretary Paul
O'Neill who was asked by a journalist
why the dollar was so strong and uh he
said what makes you think you know more
about the dollar than the hundreds of
people who trade it around the world
every day I mean the market consensus is
that well it was certainly that we would
test the all-time low which was one
pound uh one dollar and five cents which
was on 25th of Feb 1985 and we did that
overnight on Sunday so the next stop
lower below that is parity and there is
a school of thought in the market that
you could see that but I mean that did
some great charts on this earlier in the
week where he pointed to the sort of
long-term decline of Sterling going I
mean it used to be more than four
dollars uh back a century ago and it's
been one way traffic ever since it's
perfectly perfectly feasible that uh you
could see dollar parity to the Sterling
yeah you will ask that I mean do you
think that that is going to potentially
happen no one knows no one knows sorry
to be annoying but no one knows and like
Ian was saying you know I so I I the the
former chairman of the fed the U.S
Central Bank like the the place of all
places which she would have thought
would have all of the kind of details
and the abilities to model what's
happening in currencies
um I spoke to Ryan Greenspan about this
and he said we put so much effort into
trying to predict currencies you know
had the best possible data the best
possible models it was rubbish it was
rubbish so no one knows because these
things what are they they're massive
manifestations of decisions that people
are taking across the world some of
which are kind of rational some might
sometimes be irrational we just don't
know like Ian says it's entirely
plausible that it goes down to parity or
maybe even a little bit below but it's
pretty stable today and you know just
take one day at a time I know that's not
it's not very helpful but it it is the
truest we can be about this I think
nobody knows I think that's that's the
key thing it's not the case that there's
some sort of Machiavellian creature who
knows all of this no but we're kind of
in a period of lack of confidence at the
moment and that's kind of what's
determining things which again makes it
kind of quite unpredictable but means
that you could you know what's the the
reasonable value of sterling maybe it's
probably weaker than it could be but
again you know determining that's
difficult and don't forget I mean the
reason the dollar has been turbocharged
this year even before events last week
it was up 16 against Sterling on the
year the FED is tightening monetary
policy more aggressively than anyone
else they've gone far faster and far
more aggressive and if they carry on
doing that and we know that from Jay
Powell the FED chairman he said he's
prepared to risk a U.S recession to get
on inflation under control if you do
that then theoretically that means more
aggressive tightening more dollar
strength it's been interesting actually
Jane because this way we've um we
haven't had many Chief Executives or big
companies coming out and criticizing
overtly the UK government for what's uh
what's been announced
in the last few days one of the
exceptions that has been the chief
executive of Virgin Atlantic which of
course relies on strong demand for
transatlantic air travel
um and and the chief executive of Virgin
Atlantic was was very clear that he
wanted the government to reverse some of
the tax cuts announced in the mini
budget last week in order to improve the
prospects for Sterling now clearly one
chief executive is not going to
influence government policy and it's
interesting we haven't seen more
explicit criticism from the business
Community but nevertheless it was an
interesting uh you can see the real
world effects in in the economical
effects if you go you know anybody who
went holiday to America recently knows
the real world effect and Virgin
Atlantic will know that that costs three
dollars as well a lot of them are yeah
The Travelers are not getting what
they're used to
um we had a question from Rebecca she
says I have a pension scheme with my
employer is it at risk and and Ian we we
talked about pensions and and the
concerns that they were about these
guilts and people will look at this and
go hang on our pensions all of a sudden
at risk
so what we don't know from that question
is whether she's on a defined benefit or
a defined contribution pension that you
know final salary in the jargon where
your employer guarantees you uh an
income in retirement that's based on
what you were earning at the time of
your retirement or defined contribution
or money purchases it's known sometimes
which is where the risk lies with you
the retiree you put aside money in your
pension your employer will put some
money in your pension but how it
performs influences what you get out of
it at the other end so with without
knowing what Rebecca's situation is I
guess it's the one that that performs
isn't it that that would be the concern
because if you know your your pension's
safe yeah I mean again it depends on how
old she is I mean she might be in her
twenties she's got another 40 years of
her working life but if she's I mean the
issue over the last 48 hours has been
over defined benefit uh pensions in
other words the ones where your employer
guarantees you
um a pension in retirement a lot of that
actually depends on uh the the strength
of the employer themselves because
obviously if the employer goes into
Administration then potentially the
pension fund is is an unsecured creditor
and that's pretty scary but you've seen
that happening over the last few years
yeah but I mean if if she works for a
solid Blue Chip company and they've made
these sort of pension guarantees then
she would have nothing to worry about
but without knowing her specific
circumstances it's hard to say and
certainly we don't want to be alarmist
but I've I've heard anecdotal evidence
in the last few hours of pension schemes
being so worried about their funding
position corporate pension schemes large
employers where the pension trustees
have gone to the company that stands
behind the scheme and asked for the
company to lend money to the pension
scheme so that they can meet their
financial obligations now at this stage
no no names of those companies have been
disclosed but the reality is if that
that sort of request is being made by
pension trustees you can be sure that
there is some real anxiety
um among pension trustees and the and
the sponsors the the companies that
stand behind those schemes by the way
it's worth point Sorry I noticed as a
technical point and and I don't want to
labor it but it's worth actually
pointing out that higher guilt yields
and higher bond yields are actually in
effect quite good for occupational
pension schemes because pension deficits
scheme deficits and liabilities are
calculated on bond yields and one of the
reasons over the last decade we've had
all these issues with companies having
to put more money into their Pension
funds is because we've been in a period
of ultra low interest rates ultra low
bond yields so higher yields in theory
are quite good for pensions and
certainly good for narrowing scheme
deficits well staying with pensions Kane
has asked what exactly would it meant
would it have meant if Pension funds
collapsed yesterday
Ed well I mean the concern that the bank
had and I think it's very reasonable
concern you know pensions are an
enormous part of the investment
landscape of of this country and other
countries as well and if you have a
problem happening there then it can
cause a kind of ripple effect that
affects Banks so the facts obviously
companies that are kind of sponsoring
those pensions and then you see it going
throughout the system of government
bonds and when that happens all bets are
off and that's why the bank stepped in
to try and kind of nip it in the bud so
that was the concern not not just about
Pension funds as Ian said you know there
are various protections that ensure even
though that many of those funds are kind
of struggling with these Investments at
the moment uh that that there were lots
of things between you know you as a
potential beneficiary and things going
wrong over there that would potentially
click in but it's not just those Pension
funds it's the fact that it's the what a
wider threat of there being a crisis
throughout these markets that the bank
was concerned about that the difference
and it's worth just kind of going back
to that question you know that
comparison with financial crisis
back in 2008 the world's Financial
system was effectively insolvent you
know that's that was the scale of what
we were facing you know Banks across the
world were were essentially unable to
fund themselves this is a very different
world and this is a very discreet
different crisis and it has a very
different likely cause which is what
happened last Friday it's worth just
remembering that it's not like the
entire edifice is falling down it's like
there's been some problems there some
big questions about what happens when we
kind of get interest rates back to a
normal level we're all still wrestling
with that at the moment it's a really
big deal but that's it's the different
world to the 2008 World thankfully and I
think in terms of of Pensions that is is
by and large for most people the main
place that that money is saved over the
long term but Henry's question is what
is the effect on the current Financial
turmoil on savings accounts are we going
to lose our savings I mean in that
strikes me as being unlikely for every
well there's a there's a deposit
guarantee scheme backstopped by the
governments where whereby the first 85
000 pounds of your savings is guaranteed
by the government so even reach
institutions for each year absolutely
right yeah make a personal finance
reporter review yeah I've been listening
to some of the people I've interviewed
yeah so your first 85 Grand is
effectively safe but as you said after
that you've got to switch it around from
institution to institution right so
that's that's the best way to but you
know in theory if you've done that your
savings should be safe yeah right
um Mike his question is is it possible
that the whole effort from the bank of
England to stabilize the market uh could
be tipped off it says in November when
the government puts forwards their plan
in full
um well okay there's two things really
there's there's the bank of England's
intervention okay that's actually just a
two-week thing so even before we get the
government's giving their plan and at
the end of November there is the
question of whether they're going to
renew that whether they're going to roll
it over and what that actually means for
these bits of the market as Mark was
saying this this the pressures have not
gone away on many of these funds and the
way that they've structured their
Investments so that's one thing the bank
of England and its intervention here
does it need to extend it and then
there's a second thing which is whatever
the let's say the government survives
let's say they make it through let's say
that they you know markets don't have
another tumble in between now and the
end of November if they provide
something that doesn't satisfy markets
and Spooks them out then we'll have to
see I mean we you know we could have
more instability at that point because
people are watching and waiting and
looking for a credible response so again
we just have to kind of take it one day
at a time and see but yeah all eyes on
them
uh the next question this is an evil one
to throw your way Mark I know you're
going to winch there has anyone asked
the former Chancellor Rishi Cena called
he thinks what would he have done
differently and they've not given their
name
is that from you Jane no it's not right
from Russia yeah is it from an RC neck
in Yorkshire
um well look I mean the the conservative
leadership campaign was uh when it came
down to those two final con contenders
of Rishi sunak and let's trust you know
one of the fundamental differences in
their uh campaigns was the was there a
policy on the economy it was their
policy on on tax cuts this this trust
was adamant that she was going to
announce very significant tax cuts and
and Richie sunette was not in was not
minded to to do that so I mean I have no
idea what what Mr sunette thinks this
week I suspect as a as somebody's a
patriotic Brit he won't he won't be
pleased and somebody was the chancellor
until very recently he will not be at
all pleased by what by what he's seen
but clearly you know all of the factors
we've been talking the last couple of
hours the the lack of an obr forecast
the criticism from the IMF the fact that
the tax cuts that were announced last
week were not anticipated by uh markets
and investors all of those things added
up to to the kind of real crisis that
we've seen unfolding this week
um Mr sunac probably would not had he
won the leadership election and become
our prime minister he would not have
announced a similar set of measures last
week and also the question that there's
a cue almost as long as the queue we
just had outside here in Westminster to
see the queen lying and state to try and
try and get any kind of response from
British among journalists everyone wants
to know but he's keeping very quiet he
is and we know he's not going to be at
the Conservative Party Conference this
weekend as well
um uh only a few questions left Sean
I'll put this one to you in will the UK
property market crash given that over 40
of mortgage products have now been
removed from the market very good
question
um depends on his definition of Ash but
I find it inconceivable that there isn't
going to be some sort of reaction in the
property market and here's why so we've
had the bank of England raising interest
rates over the last 10 months from point
one percent to two and a quarter percent
and probably they'll go again by at
least half a point next time around it
hasn't affected mortgage borrowers that
month much because something like 94 of
mortgages taken out in the last three
years have been on a fixed rate so and I
think 74 of the overall mortgage Market
their loans are fixed so they're not
affected by higher interest rates the
the problem emerges when they start to
roll off those fixed rate deals now
something like 650 000 homeowners will
do so in the second half of this year
something like 1.2 million I think it is
1.2 million next year their mortgage
deal is going to expire they're going to
find themselves paying a hell of a lot
more for their mortgages even someone on
a very very average typical Family
Mortgage will probably be looking at
upwards of 200 pounds a month or more as
if that's if say mortgage rates get to
about six percent which I think is
pretty lightly the way we're going so
you're looking at hundreds of pounds of
extra mortgage payments in parts of the
country where houses are expensive like
London and the home county is
potentially looking at thousands of
pounds extra every month I find it
inconceivable that house prices are not
going to crack under those circumstances
now I don't want to get over you know
terrify people because you know there
are still supply and demand mismatches
in the market that's what's kept the
market afloat that ultra low interest
rates but I find it inconceivable that
the fact that all of these people's
mortgage payments are going to go up is
not going to have an impact on on the
housing market yeah and we heard from
John Boulder from from charcoal he's a
real clean clean Watcher of the housing
market saying Heath or 10 to 15 drop
would possibly happen in the market yeah
but bear in mind they've gone up by
about 15 in the last year house prices
up until recently we're going up faster
than the you know the average house
price gained more than the average
person got in their annual salary after
over the last year so I was going
gangbusters but as Ian says that's a
massive [ __ ] and people coming off their
current fixes at that Peaks next year
just at the moment the interest rates
are going to potentially hit six percent
hopefully not last question
um and it's a it's a good one from Keith
if the bank of England has to step in to
prop up the financial markets then is
this not proof of the government's
failure yes
well Keith might very well say that I
couldn't possibly comment I mean it's
it's very oh gosh how to put this
it's
it's something happened last Friday
that spooked markets and has led to
an incredible disturbance that has
caused the bank of England to have to
intervene something happened the
government would like us to believe it
was not something they did but nowhere
else around the world is facing anything
quite like this
so
either we believe that this was an
enormous coincidence and we were just
terribly unlucky and just out of nowhere
this act of God or bad luck happened or
it was down to something that happened
at 9 30 on Friday when quasi-quarters
stood up in the House of Commons and
governments always paid the price for
sterling devaluations Harold Wilson did
John Major did
seems a good point to leave it Ed Conway
Mark Kleinman and Ian thank you both
thank you all so very much great to have
you and uh thanks so much for answering
all of our viewers questions